[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la tête de ma maman on dirait tes
oncle bourré à la fin du soir
qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs je vais passer parmi vous
donner ce que vous pouvez bien entendu
non mais c'est vrai merci à vous
expliquer
je vais je vais faire des couples
auxquels je crois le plus au couple
auquel je crois le moins
le mois en plus donc Guillaume et Gilles
[Applaudissements]
un petit reggaeton
alors excuse-moi
sur la tête de ma mère c'est le
correspondant allemand qui vient chez
moi et non je suis très content madame
Hanouna
et normalement tu lui apprends des gros
mots
vous faites vraiment bien cuisine Cyril
m'a dit vous avez beaucoup cul
non mais c'est ou pas sans déconner ça
marche
hyper bien on dirait on dirait
ça va toi elle sent priseur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un porteur
je crois que j'ai passé
ce passage puisque c'est comme ça je
suis à deux doigts de te destituer de
Daniel et danser
avec batterie
est-ce que je peux vous poser une
question est-ce que vous m'autorisez si
vous m'aimez bien à réaliser mon rêve
non c'est bien Béatrice non est-ce que
vous motorisez à réaliser mon rêve non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je peux parler
c'est juste un petit moment de bonheur
avec un est allemand esthétique ça me
ferait plaisir mais si vous voulez pas
de le faire déjà pensé avant oui oui oui
quand il a dit c'est mon fantasme il a
su que c'était le mien aussi bon
alors
dites-moi alors Julie
s'il vous plait s'il vous plaît je parle
2 minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mettez-moi une musique bavaroise
mettez-vous là vous faites ce que vous
voulez mais là à mon avis ils vont
prendre de l'avance avec la galoche et
toi là faites ce que vous voulez je sais
qu'ils ont tous les deux envie de se
galocher depuis des années
c'est incroyable s'il vous plaît
mettez-nous une musique allemande
érotique
vous tapez vous tapez
musicalement qui est magnifique c'est i
no shunot aussi
ça fait beaucoup de mal à ma communauté
toujours quelqu'un en régie c'est en
train de chercher de taper musicalement
de ma vie
je suis mur
et moi je vais chanter allemand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le baiser n'est pas non plus un truc
obligatoire
je te dis je te destitue je te déteste
la galoche je tourne d'abord cette fois
la langue dans ma propre bouche déjà et
je réfléchis comment alors comment
c'était là bien non vraiment
il a envie de recommencer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous allez me prendre un tic tac chacun
et vous allez mettre la langue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars
j'ai pas une grande décision
je ne noterai pas avec Béatrice
ça va partir en cacahuète
et si vous embrassez gilet Guillaume se
rend embrasseront avec plaisir et après
Jean-Marie fera ce qu'il vous
faut bien entendu
Mathieu a dit
tu as dit tu devais aller vers une femme
avec moi je commence à y aller
de conduire c'est sur une Ferrari
à moi
combien de pas que ça euh Mathieu
comment c'était très agréable est-ce que
tu pourrais
devenir du Rubicon alors avec Delphine
ou Delphine
vraiment si c'est vraiment alors
peut-être pas filmé là mais mais est-ce
que tu pourrais franchir la barrière du
Rubicon alors il a les lèvres très
douces et pas que les lèvres
et quand il vous tient
vrai tenue et ça ça fait vraiment du
bien
alors Mathieu Mathieu Mathieu est-ce que
tu serais prêt à vivre une nouvelle
expérience avec Delphine
alors c'est bizarre comme question là
comme ça si je peux commencer
[Applaudissements]